. I have breaking news about authoritarian
repression of the media for you.
The president, Donald Trump, said yesterday
it should be illegal for the news media to
cover and report on the corona virus pandemic
when there's an election about to happen.
Now, as you may know, we have more than two
hundred and thirty thousand deaths in the
U.S. from Corona virus.
We have one of the highest per capita case
rates in the world.
We have one of the highest per capita death
We have four percent of the population and
20 percent of the deaths.
We are potentially heading into the worst
period for the U.S. in history from the standpoint
of public health.
And it is imperative that every American understand
what's going on, rising cases, rising deaths.
What the stakes are and what we must do.
And Trump wants it to be illegal for news
media to report on a pandemic during a pandemic
because he's trying to hide it so he can get
himself another four years in the Oval Office
because he has failed miserably in dealing
with the virus.
Trump tweeting, quote, We have made tremendous
progress with the China virus, but the fake
news refuses to talk about it this close to
the election.
Cauvin Cauvin covered is being used by them
in total coordination in order to change our
great early election numbers should be an
election law violation.
Trump then complaining that CNN is talking
about covered during one of his three rallies
yesterday.
Take a look.
Can you turn on CNN?
That's all the cover covered, covered, pandemic
covered, covered, covered.
You know why they're trying to talk to everybody
out of voting.
People aren't buying it.
CNN, you dumb bastard said.
How delusional is this?
Is this evil?
Is it sociopathic?
Is it merely dictatorial?
This is happening in the middle of the United
States hitting new single day records for
cases over the weekend.
Eighty one thousand cases on Friday.
Seventy nine thousand cases on Saturday.
Records.
We're in Kovik.
Hell in the United States.
And Trump is saying it should be illegal for
the news media to pick stories.
I thought this guy was against regulation.
I thought this guy was about letting everybody
do what they want to do and stopping oppressive
government into it.
It should be illegal to report on the pandemic.
And it's also even funnier because it to the
extent any of this is funny.
It should be against election law.
Trump says the media should be bound by election
law in what they can cover.
They're not even running for anything.
Election law typically applies to candidates
campaigns and to donors.
Textbook fascism.
This is a lunatic wannabe dictator.
Now news about 100 year pandemics should be
against the law.
Trump says Biden should be in jail, but he
won't tell us what crimes were committed.
He says he will lock up the Bidens.
Trump has been putting pressure on William
Barr to investigate the Bidens.
Trump won't commit to a peaceful transfer
of power, but I don't think it will work anyway
in the sense of trying to suppress the fact
that 230000 realistically, three hundred and
ten thousand, if you actually look at access
mortality, hundreds of thousands of people,
needless to say, have died on his watch trying
to suppress it.
I don't think we'll make people forget about
it.
And I don't think it will make people forgive
Donald Trump, not the sane, rational people
anyway.
Although there's plenty of outrageous people
around as well.
But the most important thing to debunk here
is the idea that Kofod had to be bad for politicians.
It's been horrible for the world as far as
tragedy and death and suffering.
But politically, it's only bad if you mishandle
it.
New Zealand's president was reelected in a
landslide because she successfully kept the
pandemic under control.
She also happens to be a normal person who
is not completely out of touch with reality.
So Trump could be sailing to reelection if
he had handled this correctly.
Serious questions to conservatives.
Do you support Trump's statement that it should
be against the law for the news to report
on a pandemic because there's an election
close by?
Seems indefensible.
And yet I'm continuously surprised by what
the right is willing to support.
Should the media be banned from discussing
covered close to an election?
The majority of Trump I'm seeing online now.
These are just the ones willing to comment
online.
There could be a vast silent majority that
is against this.
But what I'm seeing online from Trump's is
it was taken out of context.
It Trump only said it as a joke.
The media should be banned from covering it
because they lie about it.
If they told the truth, they should be allowed
to cover it.
But because the fake news media is lying about
the pandemic, they shouldn't be allowed to
cover it.
I want to hear from Trump lists.
Do you agree with this?
Should it be illegal to cover coronavirus?
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.